[Musica]
buonasera buonasera
dalla presentazione dal modo con cui
sono entrate avete capito che sono
vecchio
e però negli ultimi dieci anni come
diceva la mia gentile presentatrice mi
sono occupato insieme a un meraviglioso
gruppo di giovani ed è il messaggio poi
finale che potrei lasciare di questo
progetto che quello che riguarda la
plasticità del cervello e la mano
robotica cominciando vorrei condividere
con voi alcuni concetti non vi
spaventate sembrano complesse una realtà
sono facili immaginate che ognuno di
questi bottoncini di questi due cose che
voi vedete così abbiamo i contatti tra
cellule nervose si chiamano sinapsi che
quando io mi sono laureato ci dicevano
essere congelate dalla nascita in poi il
cervello secondo gli studiosi dell'epoca
era molto plastico quando si era molto
giovani ma poi diventava praticamente
congelato identico per il resto della
propria vita
molti studi inclusi non stiamo
dimostrato che anche alla mia età e
anche oltre
anche il cervello della compianta levi
montalcini era ancora plastico e videro
questi studi che se io ripeto molte
volte lo stesso stimolo che insiste
sulla stessa sinapsi l'area del contatto
tende ad aumentare e se continuo
addirittura vengono emesse nuove sinapsi
quindi si facilita enormemente il
passaggio delle imposte come se pensate
che meraviglia delle nostre strade si
allargassero in funzione del traffico
giornaliero che insiste su di esse ma al
contrario se io quelle sinapsi e poi
circuiti e le uso poco
piano piano tendono a degenerare anche
se poi vedremo non degenerano mai in
modo totale quindi una dinamica del
cervello che rende le comunicazioni tra
cellule nervose estremamente plastico ed
estremamente cangiante nel corso delle
nostre esperienze quotidiane
delle nostre emozioni della memoria di
hanoi depositiamo alla fine di ogni
giornata di quello che apprendiamo
studiando o facendo esperienze in tutto
questo si inserisce il problema della
mano robotica vedremo poi meglio perché
perché abbiamo due grandi scuole che si
sono confrontate negli anni e
ringraziando dio sta vincendo sempre di
più questa nei primi decenni si pensava
che la dopo un'amputazione si potesse
soltanto mettere una mano artificiale di
tipo cosmetico al massimo nei migliore
dei casi una pinza che si chiude si apre
senza nessuna sensibilità senza nessuna
graduazione di di forza e di velocità di
movimento
negli ultimi anni con gli avanzamenti
della ricerca in ambito elettronico
meccanica ed informatico si è andato
sempre più affermando l'idea che la mano
deve essere funzionale da robocop in poi
la mano robotica deve servire a qualche
cosa e non soltanto alla cosmesi
però noi ci scontravamo con l'idea che
il nostro cervello una volta privato
dell'esperienza di possedere un braccio
e una mano perdesse le centraline che
controllavano quel braccio e quella mano
e quelle dita perduta e che quindi e
dopo un po di mesi e dopo un po di tempo
non ci fosse più la possibilità di
ricollegare in qualche modo quelle aree
in realtà studi recenti e anche da parte
del nostro gruppo hanno dimostrato
questi queste noci che voi vedete
dall'altro sono dei cervelli e il
cervello di una persona reale e le aree
colorate sono quelle che si attivano nel
corso di un movimento della mano opposta
perché i due emisferi controllano l'arto
superiore dell'altro lato vedete come si
attivano le bene le aree durante il
movimento della mano integra ma vedete
che se c'è grosse zolle di neuroni che
funzionano anche quando vengono fatti
dei movimenti pensati per che la mano
amputata non c'è più ma il soggetto
pensa di fare dei movimenti si attivano
delle aree cerebrali molto simili a
quelle cosiddette normali e quindi non
ci siamo detti ma caspita allora anche a
distanza di anni rimangono delle
centraline
potremmo teoricamente utilizzare se
ricolleghiamo quel cervello ad una mano
artificiale questa roba qui provoca un
grande interesse
un grande interesse nel mondo i primi
casi che abbiamo fatto sono usciti sulla
bbc la cnn la globo tv in tutto il sud
america questo è un ragazzo italo
brasiliano che è stato il nostro primo
candidato
vedete che la mano in realtà non è
collegato a lui perché il primo
prototipo che sarà 15 kg molto molto di
più circa 10 volte di più di un
avambraccio di una mano reali però era
collegato con degli elettrodi come poi
vedremo inseriti nei nervi del
moncherino e lui aveva imparato con la
sua volontà a utilizzare una strategia
che permetteva ai nostri computer di
interpretare i segnali in uscita dai
suoi nervi e di mandare i comandi
corretti alla mano che li eseguiva
questo solo che fare un po di pubblicità
al fatto che questo sono cose di grande
interesse ora noi come possiamo
collegare il cervello ad una mano
artificiale
uno dei metodi più diciamo difficili ma
per noi più naturali e 15 come madre
natura è sempre più brava dei
ricercatori le cose le fa sempre meglio
abbiamo pensato che i nervi periferici
che rimangono dentro il moncherino dopo
l'amputazione sono i veicoli giusti sia
per estrarre il segnale legato al
comando del movimento che proviene dal
cervello sia per inviare le sensibilità
di una mano artificiale sensorizzati che
dicono a quel cervello che il movimento
è stato eseguito bene che dicono in quel
cervello che tipo di oggetto sta
toccando ed esplorando con la mano che
dicono a quel cervello
quanta forza sta esercitando la sua
presa per poter collegare però sembra è
facile dirlo ma vi assicuro che ogni
passo è costato anni di sacrifici e di
lavori per poter collegare questi i
nervi al cervello di un amputato ci sono
varie possibilità una delle prime era
quella di creare un
griglia di elettrodi sottilissimi sono
come degli anni che sono un decimo di un
ago normale utilizzato in sartoria
inseriti all'interno del nervo ma si è
visto che questa la distanza con i
movimenti dei muscoli le contrazioni dei
muscoli provocava dei danni
poi si è pensato di utilizzare delle
cuffie da mettere tutti attorno al nervo
questo è la raffigurazione ingrandita di
un nervo guardate quante fibre quanta
roba ci corre dentro e questo è tutta
roba che mette in contatto voi e il
vostro cervello con l'ambiente che vi
circonda voi ad occhi chiusi quando
entrate nella vostra stanza di notte è
riuscito a trovare l'interruttore della
luce senza problemi
se non avesse tutte queste fibre
collegate ai recettori della cute e la
capacità di controllare i muscoli della
mano non sarebbe possibile questa
semplicissima azione
noi abbiamo sposato questa soluzione
piquet è quella di introdurre degli
elettrodi molto sottili rappresentati da
questa specie di aco che come un capello
all'interno del nervo questi questo
capello è dotato di una serie di
contatti che registrano i segnali che
corrono lungo le fibre ad un nervo e
possono essere collegati ad e gli
stimolatori che attraverso quei contatti
mandano degli impulsi elettrici che poi
le fiber propagano verso il cervello
quindi una via in due direzioni
esattamente come avviene nei nervi di un
soggetto sano il nervo di un soggetto
sano e un'autostrada molte corsie alcune
che vanno verso i muscoli in periferia
altre che vanno verso il centro portando
le informazioni sensoriali
questi sono questi sono i veri eroi sono
i nostri soggetti che noi abbiamo
selezionato un po da tutto il mondo
l'italo brasiliano è stato il primo
dennis che un ragazzo danese a cui è
esploso un petardo in mano perché questo
non avviene soltanto in italia e nel sud
italia ma a quanto pare avviene
nord europa durante i festeggiamenti di
capodanno ha perso il braccio
l'avambraccio e la mano e le dita di
sinistra e lui qui sta lavorando abbiamo
inserito dei nervi nei degli elettrodi
nei nervi del suo moncherino gli
mandiamo degli stimoli e lui a seconda
di quello che viene stimolato ci
riferisce di sentire qualcosa in questo
caso qualcosa sul pollice della mano che
non ha più in questo caso qualcosa
sull'indice della mano e del dito che
non ha più in questo caso qualcosa sul
palmo della mano settimane di lavoro in
cui si fa una mappatura di quelle che
sono le fibre e di contatti che
producono le singole sensibilità e
quindi il lavoro sostanzialmente detto
così
ripeto è molto semplice consiste
inizialmente in una chi in una selezione
della persona in una chirurgia che
genera e dura alcune ore perché
l'elettro dove inserito con precisione
con il microscopio chirurgiche va
fissato in modo che poi il movimento del
moncherino non provochi spostamenti e
poi si comincia a lavorare in
laboratorio
collegando gli elettrodi ai computer che
debbono imparare a decodificare il
messaggio che corre lungo i nervi in
uscita per produrre il movimento debbono
mandare l'informazione sensoriale sotto
forma di piccole scariche elettriche al
cervello di quella persona per fargli
percepire che cosa lui sta toccando in
quel momento si è andati oltre le ultime
generazioni questo è un polpastrello
elettronico e un polpastrello diciamo
meccanico sotto cui vengono fatte
scorrere delle superfici e diciamo voi
potete immagino spero apprezzare che
questa è una superficie con delle
irregolarità molto grossolane queste
dell'irregolarità un pochino meno
grossolane queste sono ancora più
sottili e queste sottilissime bene il
soggetto a questo dito artificiale
collegato ai nervi messi dentro il suo
moncherino ed impara privato
completamente di qualsiasi informazione
visiva
a riconoscere se sta toccando una
superficie rugosa grossolana oppure più
raffinata e più sottile impara anche a
capire alla angolatura del movimento
delle singole dita ed impara anche a
riconoscere se sta toccando un oggetto
che piccolo perché un oggetto piccolo ci
permette di chiudere molto le dita e
quindi noi dalla chiusura delle ditte
percepiamo la grandezza la forma
dell'oggetto e a seconda della pressione
che questo comporta sui sensori se
l'oggetto è piccolo e duro se è piccolo
e morbido se grande e morbido se grande
duro
vi sembrerà qualcosa di grossolano vi
assicuro che per chi non ha più una mano
da anni è qualcosa che fa piangere per
la gioia perché si ritorna a percepire
cose che si erano perdute si pensava che
fossero perdute per sempre
questa è una storia bella secondo me
della parte bella dell'italia 11 anni di
ricerche attraverso una serie di
progetti europei in tante città europee
perché prima di arrivare a fare la
sperimentazione dell'uomo che è stata
fatta unicamente in italia è unicamente
a roma si è passati per tutta una serie
di fasi di prototipo di studi sulla
sulle componenti biologiche degli
elettrodi che veniva inseriti nel corpo
per essere certi che non fossero tossici
sulla non innocuità delle stimolazioni
elettriche sul fatto che non ci fosse
rigetto non ci fossero reazioni quindi
tutta una serie di fasi sperimentali
portati avanti e barcellona ad amsterdam
piuttosto che a copenhagen a stoccolma e
in francia per l'album peli e per lo
stimolatore ma il grosso della
progettazione sulla mano che una mano
meravigliosa e una mano che praticamente
potrebbe suonare il pianoforte una mano
artificiale in grado di compiere tutti i
movimenti con gli stessi gradi di
libertà di una mano umana
quindi non la pinza di vecchia memoria è
stata fatta a pisa la scuola superiore
sant'anna e il politecnico di losanna da
un bel gruppo di italiani molto
brillanti e purtroppo ne perdiamo ogni
giorno troppi si è trasferito per
trovare lavoro e per poter mettere in
atto le loro capacità di pensiero e di
ricerca vivere senza una mano
[Musica]
potete provare voi a non usare la mano
destra per una giornata ea vedere come
vi trovate nelle cose più banali di
questo mondo nella la ciardi bottoni
nella pettinarmi nel lavarsi il viso nel
fare la vostra toeletta nel muovervi
dentro casa nel cucinare nel guidare la
macchina e scoprirete quanto è
importante avercelo entrambe e quanto è
problematico privarsene di una in più il
problema non è solo della privazione ma
anche nel fatto che oltre alla sensi
alla classicità buona esiste anche una
plasticità cattiva i neuroni si
riconnettono tra di loro ed erano
generano delle sensazioni che non
esistono nella realtà per esempio in un
amputata o continuare ad avvertire la
parte mancante del proprio corpo ma in
un modo doloroso la mano attaccata al
moncherino o distante due metri dal
moncherino con un dolore intenso che ti
affligge tutta la giornata quindi il di
il dolore dell'arto fantasma è una delle
sindromi più problematiche e anche mal
controllata da farmaci e quant'altro
quindi ci sono dei problemi anche
clinici importanti da affrontare
quindi l'idea era di vedere se possiamo
ricominciare a sentire se effettivamente
le centraline che controllano la mano
che è stata tolta dall'incidente
nell'intervento chirurgico da qualsiasi
altro problema sono ancora in qualche
modo come le rose del deserto capaci di
rivivere se noi gli portiamo un po
d'acqua cioè se noi gli facciamo sentire
che c'è nuovamente una mano che
appartiene a quel corpo in questi dieci
anni sono stati studiati cinque
candidati due signore italiane e tre
candidati stranieri e ci avviamo a fare
l'ultimo impianto sperimentale
all'inizio del prossimo anno e poi
chiudere la parte di ricerca chiudere
la nostra parte perché da quel momento
in poi subentrerà la parte industriale
commerciale per produrre delle mani a
costi sufficientemente bassi da
permettere a tutti gli amputati oa chi
possibile ampio numero di imputati di
poterne fruire questo è un breve video
che vuole un pochino riassumere di
quello che vi ho detto questo signore è
un capitano dell'aeronautica ecuadoregna
che nel corso di un incidente di lavoro
ha perso l'avambraccio e la mano di
sinistra per lui ancora più importante
perché era mancino è mancino e qui già
vedete con quale destrezza vi assicuro
che nell'arco di pochi giorni di poche
settimane questi soggetti riprendono a
controllare perfettamente la mano come
se come se avessero sempre fatto e
quindi essendo questi che sia farini
bianchi sono dei sensori molto ricchi
che sono messi sulle punte delle dita a
questi sono i cani che vengono inseriti
dentro i nervi del moncherina attraverso
i nervi l'impulso raggiunge il cervello
del soggetto del soggetto pur essendo
privato di vista e privato di
informazioni acustiche e in grado di
riconoscere la forma dell'oggetto che
sta con la sua umana artificiale come
subito artificiale esplorando e
afferrando è in grado di sollevarlo
senza farselo scivolare o senza romperlo
perché noi facciamo facilmente
solleviamo facilmente un bicchiere ma
nemmeno ci accorgiamo che la forza e
regolata affinché il bicchiere non cada
mette si spezzi è in grado di scrivere è
in grado di guidare la macchina nella
prossima diapositiva quindi e questo è
un prototipo che risale a un paio di
anni e mezzo fa avete visto che portava
uno zaino sulle spalle perché la power
unit era ancora molto ingombrante e
tutta questa roba che sta qui fuori per
collegare ma nel prossimo
tutto sarà miniaturizzato dentro
l'invaso della mano artificiale per cui
di fatto
volta ricoperta di pelle artificiale che
altamente senso realizzata si riuscirà
ad avere una mano ed un braccio che
bissina fuori assomigliano veramente
molto a quello che madre natura ci ha
dato
prima dell'incidente quindi il il
cervello come chi impara nuovamente e
rapidamente perché le centraline che
c'erano tornano in gioco con molta
facilità non era una morte non erano
secche possono essere rivitalizzate e
quindi il soggetto per esempio riconosce
che questo è qualcosa di relativamente
morbido e non lo stringe troppo per
romperlo ma se fosse di vetro
riconoscerebbe che qualcosa di
relativamente duro e la stretta sarebbe
sicuramente maggiore la nostra signora
intenditrice siciliana che ha perso il
braccio all'interno del proprio lavoro
sotto una macchina che produce dolciumi
la utilizza regolarmente per cucinare
avevamo qualcosa di più romantico mentre
staccava una rosa lì ci vuole un grande
controllo per esercitare la forza la
presa e il tiraggio giusto guida la
macchina l'avete visto io mi fermerei
qui dicendo soltanto alcune cose
conclusive soprattutto indirizzate ai
giovani che sono tanti io sono vecchio
sono 70 anni suonati è però la passione
che avevo 45 anni fa quando ho
cominciato è rimasta la stessa e ogni
mattina mi sveglio dicendo al mio lavoro
la mia professione alla mia ricerca è un
altro giorno insieme finché morte non ci
separi
e quello che vi auguro a tutti quanti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]